hello in the last video about
transformers that integrated vision and
language we spoke about the pre-trained
ception
where this is how we like to call the
many stages of pre-training that a
transformer undergoes in this video we
will give more details about the
pre-training strategies that are usually
employed for transformers like birth and
we will handle language only
transformers end birth based
transformers integrating vision end
language we will start with the
Transformers that process only language
with the first strategy masked language
modelling usual language models that
came before birth predicted words from
left to right so their context was based
only on what was written on the left but
birth where B stands for bi-directional
can look into both directions by being
tasked to predict one must token while
very important being allowed to see the
whole sentence this is what is called
masked language modeling and by
following this procedure the word
vectors are contextual they are
dynamically computed in a sentence
looking at both left and right context
this makes natural language processing
with words so powerful because these
dynamic word vectors carry a lot of
information from the context being able
to disambiguate words this makes natural
language processing with bread so
powerful because this dynamic word
vector is carry a lot of information
from the context so they are able to
disambiguate where it's very well and
capture core reference for example now
you are certainly curious how we choose
what words or tokens to mask in which
not to mask well there is no complicated
mechanism on this part it's just
randomness because 15% of the tokens are
chosen randomly and then masked and
predicted and these tokens chosen for
masking are completely replaced by a
special mask token in order to prevent
training a cheating model that would
look at the word we try to mask but this
mask token appears only during the
masked language modeling stage and not
on a downstream task like on question
answering so what do we do in this case
to ameliorate this mismatch at a pre
training stage out of t is 15% of tokens
that are chosen to be predicted only 80%
of them are replaced with the mask token
and the rest 20% is replaced by another
random word that most probably does not
make sense like in this example where
recognize a person was replaced by shout
person but because we have this random
token inserted which makes no sense
means that our models is also
occasionally noise encouraging Birds
to be less biased towards the mask token
when looking at a whole context okay so
that was it what we need to know about
the inner workings of masked language
modeling and we are ready to move on to
the next pre training strategy which is
next sentence prediction how the name
already describes it the model has to
predict if a given sentence is a good
continuation of the sentence it is
currently looking at let's break it down
a little we have the sentence that the
model is currently looking at and in
this task it is also getting a new
sentence a possible next sentence to the
current one in 50% of the cases it is
really the next sentence but in other
50% of the cases it is a random sentence
this training procedure teaches the
model something about coherence and
long-range dependencies that are
spanning between sentences and that was
it for the models learning from only
language what if we learn from
images too this is where it gets really
cool for vision and language
transformers are also trained on masked
language modeling but additionally on
three other tasks which make a lot of
sense the first task is sentence image
alignment where the multimodal
transformer gets an image and a sentence
and has to decide if this sentence is a
suitable description of the image and
predicts an alignment score it receives
both positive and negative examples to
learn also by counterexample how the two
modalities vision and language align
it's not so complicated right so we can
move on to the fourth pre training
strategy employed by the multimodal
transformer which is region
classification this one's really
intuitive we remember as we explained in
the multimodal transformer video link
below how the transformer works on
sequences and also sick ventral eyes is
the image by looking at regions in the
image and encoding them with a deep
network from computer vision well like
we mask words from the textual sequence
we can also mask the image region and
their features and try to predict what
the mask the region is this training
strategy helps the model focus also on
the visual details which is a very
important contribution given that
anecdotally the textual modality often
overshadows the visual one what I mean
to say is that often models understand
what a task is about but looking only at
the text without having any utility from
looking at the image this is one reason
more to Train by this strategy to
classify image regions and we are
already at the last strategy which takes
the region classification from before to
the next level which is regression
instead for the model to say what a
masked image region is it has to be even
more detailed by specifying the feature
vector describing this image of course
this task is much harder to solve
classifications are easy since the
output space is very restricted
and predefined regressions however are
harder with a big end continuous output
space so this is it here we end our
pre-trained ception journey to put it
into perspective the birth models
usually goes through a pre training
stage where the strategies we just
discussed masked language modeling next
sentence prediction are applied for a
multi modal transformer that integrates
vision and language additionally to the
pre-training tasks we had already we
also take sentence image alignment
region classification and region feature
regression into account then this model
that has learned general features on
text and possibly on images is ready to
be applied on another more interesting
downstream tasks like sentiment
classification currents resolution
machine translation and so on and
because the model was pre trained in
stage 1 the performance on the
downstream tasks at stage two benefits
considerably I hope you have learned
something about the training procedure
of Transformers if you like this video
do not forget to hit a like and
subscribe buttons and see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]